[Music]
[Laughter]
this podcast is brought to you by cash
up with cash app investing you can turn
as little as one dollar into the start
of a valuable portfolio and you can
conjure powerful stock trading energies
with this simple ritual start by
lighting incense sandalwood and myrrh
are best for stabilizing a bearish stock
but nag Champa works in a pinch dress in
flowing rain raw linen so that market
forces can move through you draw a
circle of salt around you and face south
as you make trades for your protection
to invoke a good rate of return set out
a small bone china finger bowl of honey
goat tallow as an offering to the
spirits of past Fed Chairman just don't
leave it out after that market closes or
it will attract gremlins if you can
trade on the shore at a cliffside
near a seismic fault line or anywhere
else rival elements meet these are
places of power and they will make your
stocks powerful to finally swiftly move
to the App Store or Google Play Store
and download the cash app today forget
not to use the ancient promo code
congrats to receive $10 and cash app
will also donate $10 to the trevor
project brokerage services are provided
by cash app investing a subsidiary of
square and member s IPC
[Music]
we make money doing those ads dude my
voice is beautiful what's up it's a it's
a episode 151 of congratulations and you
know how we do you know how we do but
it's gonna be a [ __ ] maybe a good
episode but who knows dude who knows I'm
going to be in Chicago New Year's Eve
come celebrate with me my babies we've
got three shows two of them are sold out
one of them the last one is at I think
10 o'clock on New Year's Eve and let's
let's bring in the new year together now
people always say ring in the new year
together and I don't know really what
that means because it should absolutely
only be bring in the new year because
you're bringing in the new year you're
not a bell but um yeah ring in bring in
they're just losing to be bring in ring
in in in gain the new year don't give a
[ __ ] but come up with me Chicago go to
crystal e.com to get tickets and that's
what's up and if you come out come with
me dude Konvict Muzik
whoa North Carolina in the South
Carolina South Carolina North Carolina
but yeah so that's that's what we're
doing in New Year's Eve and so if you
get and go get your tickets I'm pretty
sure that third show that well it's
actually the fourth show and Chicago
theater but I'm sure pretty sure that'll
sell out too but uh so get your tickets
now I just saw that you trailer I'm not
in the trailer doesn't make me upset yes
am I still in the show yes is it did I
convince myself while watching it that
am I not in it because of the fact that
I'm not it may be the love interest yes
but then there's two other people that
aren't belong visitors in the prim in
the preview yeah
is it alright yeah it's fine dude I'm
still in it but anyway uh you know
that's that I mean that I'm in the I'm
in the I'm in you and it's premieres and
what a week is it what is it now
yeah about about well no ten days so
that will come out and I can't wait I
don't know if I'll watch it I will watch
it but the thing is I don't always watch
the things I do people come up to me and
they're like hey Sean um and and I liked
it and I say okay don't know or they say
hey saw it didn't like it and I say you
know what don't know because I don't
know um but anyway I mean that and I
can't wait for it to come out to be in
that sexy show even though it's
definitely a wild thing I remember
talking to Joe I'll say Joe because it's
cool because I feel like he's talking to
that actor that plays Joe you know you
know anyway I was talking to him and he
I was like dude did you think it was
crazy like reading that script
especially the time now that it has to
do with like a stalker and like he he
like kills and stalks women and [ __ ] he
was like yeah I was really unsure about
taking it I think he turned it down at
first he said but anyway the fact that
they make that show good but still about
what it's about and still make you want
to kind of yeah yeah I don't know if you
root for Joe
it's a [ __ ] interesting show man but
it's really good this first season I
didn't see the second season first
season was amazing and it's so bin jabal
man but you should check it out before
you watch this second season of you but
to make me want to watch a guy who
stalks women for however many episodes
ten episodes and I'm and I don't want to
be like I'll [ __ ] this guy I don't want
to watch this is really a testament to
the writers and the producers and the
directors and the actors in the show so
good job on that and I'm in season two
so check out season one before you see
season two and I don't
besides that Minoo what is this if you
won let's try to see one Oh Indy beating
oh this [ __ ] thing dude made me laugh
so much this guy in the beginning he's
trying to say and he's saying so many
different things than in the beginning
okay this is a popular YouTube clip so
in sec one face one in the be linking
Efron in the Indy beanie in the bean
engi and wrong twice yeah yeah yeah like
you nailed it yeah no that wasn't like
you know that that was like yeah I know
I know I know I [ __ ] up and I'm gonna
get I'll try it again but I know this is
the word I have problems with let's
start it over in sec one face one in the
beginning in the indie beanie in the
beginning yeah yeah in the bin engage in
deepening key of Huaraz in need in the
deepening game
oh well guys got a real problem huh guys
get a real problem doesn't he Wow now I
want to say look here's the deal it's
probably not his first language because
of the accent I get it but ho still dude
hey how about still sunward sledders you
got letters in your language right put
them all in that order and just say
those in a beginning inning in the mini
ganging in the biggest in the meaning uh
in PCB Ning Jing wow dude he if you
haven't seen this video I want you if
you're listening to this I want you to
imagine the guy who's doing this
and I want you to imagine the shirt he's
wearing okay now I want you to just the
first shirt that comes to mind while
you're listening to this okay right here
in sec one imagine anyone not telling
you what it is in DB linking imagine the
shirt okay now I want you to know that's
the shirt he's wearing because there's
only one shirt this guy would wear and
it's the shirt that's the shirt and if
you imagine it and you're any sort of
smart this is I mean wow dude in the in
the beanie in the bean engi my favorite
parts two of the two my parts are when
he goes yeah twice
yeah no yeah yeah and when the other guy
comes in dude that's just like where is
he first of all indeed yeah Oh guys so
mad this improper he cannot this
improper its beginning never mind
the comments first comic legend says
he's still been inking listen listen
properly
wow dude that's so funny man for some
reason that makes me think of the
[ __ ] beanie sigel when he you know
this the the Goodfellas man this made me
laugh so beginning here
Goodfellas beginning scene this is the
first thing that he says no I want to
say it's far back he says as far back as
I can remember I always wanted to be a
gangster right let me see as far back
this and then here here
and it's not that oh yeah is this it
sir Martin Scorsese the music edit
States yeah to me alright let's get into
it
to me goddamnit me is this it
goddamnit yes I don't know where it is
as far back as I can remember I always
wanted to be a gangster dude hard work
pays off
babies harder it pays off it's farm back
cuz I remember uh is here we go as far
back as I could remember I always wanted
to be a gangster as far back as I can
remember I always wanted to be a
gangster it's pretty good impression
okay how about when beanie sigel does it
dude beanie sigel he goes as far as back
as I can remember as far as back says it
whatever I don't want to [ __ ] look
for it dude you should have set it up
better yes dude I don't give a [ __ ] dude
I do this podcast for me I do it for me
I do it for me and as far as back as I
can remember I always wanted to be a
gangster dude I don't I'm not I don't
want to do the work dude I want to do
the work and I and I did the work you
understand this is my life dude this
place is my [ __ ] life I live my life
in a [ __ ] and I say what I say and I've
lived all my [ __ ] 39 years and then I
talk about what I want to talk about my
pockets I already did all the work
comedian through and through it's
ripping out of my pores babies okay so
when I go on stage I got crafted
material now I'm upset that I said
crafted yes when someone says they're
honing the craft as an actor do I get
blood-curdling mad yeah all right but I
still do that [ __ ] don't ever say you're
honing your craft if you're an actor
dude he paces [ __ ]
if you say you're honing your craft it
piece of [ __ ] but I already did all the
work dude
so I got to look up time codes now man
no dude comedians through through
so anyway dude listen to my life dude
as far back as I can remember I always
wanted to be a comedian crap bad letdown
s-some Martin Scorsese dude why honestly
do you listen to that I don't give a
[ __ ] dude why do you live I'm I'm you
know what man
I'm losing my mind and it's fine it
honestly it's fine because it's fine to
lose your mind in this world there's so
many crazy people in power right now and
it doesn't [ __ ] matter
you can be [ __ ] suppor fall and still
lose your [ __ ] mind look at Trump
he's crazy he just told Nancy Pelosi
that her teeth are gonna fall out of his
eyeball fall out of her face that's the
president for that ass you can do
whatever you want and you know what you
just keep getting older and you keep
[ __ ] getting more wrinkles and I got
[ __ ] not only do I have lower back
pain but bro I got tennis elbow now what
the [ __ ] what am i a [ __ ] housewife
dude I swear to God I have tennis elbow
and it hurts so bad right here it's
because I [ __ ] did the kettlebells
like this and holding them and you're
using so many [ __ ] muscle Twitter's
that you don't use you're trying to hold
it up and I and there were so many
muscles were firing man and then my
elbow said you know what we're gonna
make it all tennis dude we I got [ __ ]
tennis elbow now like a lady god damn it
dude and my lower back there's other
pains I forget about I don't know man
all I know is what I what I truly know
is if you [ __ ] what I want and here's
what I want to know and this is what
I've all been breaking it down to if you
get to the airport and you're one of
those people that you that that go to
the cafes or the restaurants or the or
the or the or the Starbucks before the
check-in you're a communist us happening
in your life that you go to the airport
and eat before you check-in first of all
the good [ __ ] is all beyond security
they know not to who opens a restaurant
who opens a Chili's do it before the
check-in
what [ __ ] goes and thinks woo got to
the airport let's chill before I get
pissed off security sucks get it all
over with and then go to Chili's if
you're at Chili's before you're [ __ ]
taking [ __ ] out of your pockets you're a
legit sociopath dude
I did it once because I got to the
Albuquerque Airport because it's so
small cuz nobody wants to be there cuz
Albuquerque absolutely sucks donkey
balls
and I got there a little too early and I
ate there at the restaurant bro they
have a restaurant a full-on restaurant
with a hostess that doesn't say seat
yourselves they say wait to be seated
because why who burns time at the
airport before you [ __ ] check-in got
to the airport way too early I'm talking
about early you know why cuz I wanted to
get the [ __ ] out of there that's why you
know why cuz Albuquerque so I was there
way too early and I was like you know
what for the first time ever I'm gonna
have a meal before I even check in
because nobody's even checking in
because nobody's in Albuquerque cuz
Albuquerque ok so I ate a whole full
meal like a burrito or some [ __ ] you
know I mean you know how I like to keep
it healthy but also sometimes it's all
out the window when you're traveling
when you're at the airports all out the
window so I got a burrito or whatever it
is and then I [ __ ] you know what do
you call it ate it there and then I
checked in and it was all fine but dude
if you go to like LAX or Logan or JFK
and you're [ __ ] chilling before
that's crazy
what restaurant would open a place up
before check-in it's already hard to
have a restaurant it's like one of the
toughest [ __ ] businesses and you're
gonna oh that's like opening up a
restaurant like yeah like you know what
I don't I honestly in it's like open up
and it opening up a beinging in the
beginning opening its it's like opening
up a restaurant anywhere in [ __ ]
Albuquerque that's what it's like in the
beginning in the beginning in the
beginning bro Eenie DB why is he saying
any don't add air after in it's just in
[ __ ] yourself up adding syllables
before you even get to the hard part
anything being nging dude silver bells
silver bells
it's crema steam in the city rim bling
hear them Rea hang it's Christmas time I
hate when they do that part when they
bend it like that like they're talented
dude don't beat that all I want for
Christmas song is [ __ ] number one
again Mariah Carey dude Mariah Carey
Mariah Carey dude what's her middle was
Mariah Carey's middle name it's Mariah
Carey
dude 1994 that chick came out and she
was just like oh I'm on for who knew
every year [ __ ] dude every single
year that shit's number one that's just
number one dude Christmas is [ __ ]
amazing man Mariah Carey dude if I swear
to God if I get rich like that which
won't happen because of this podcast
keeping me down if I get rich like that
dude I'm [ __ ] dressing like Mariah
Carey with long flowy [ __ ] gowns I
don't give a [ __ ] I'll buy all green
[ __ ] only wear green for a year I'll
make up my own language like straight no
you know what I don't even do it I'll be
I'll just talk in tongues around people
and people will be like what is he
saying and I'll just be like flatly PO
Jin Yan flatly put Giggy on and I'll get
mad at people when they don't understand
me
what slightly pooja Dionne at [ __ ]
Starbucks okay I don't know just give
him a coffee I don't give a [ __ ] dude
I'll buy all the cars and just crash
them slowly into Avon's just really
slowly in or rite-aid and then leave
them there and get out a noob or some
another to my other car I don't I sort
of got to for real dude if you give me
all the money shits changing [ __ ] is
absolutely changing these [ __ ] dorks
with all this money they don't do [ __ ]
with it dude
Bill Gates is gonna leave his kid
[ __ ] 10 million oh dude get out of
here Bill Gates leave your kid all the
money bro
I can't even tell you if I had so much
if I had [ __ ] of course no Dunst
naturally I've got no Dunst but if I had
[ __ ] that Bill Gates money that creme
de la creme right Steve Jobs of course
he died rest in peace
but if I had that [ __ ] oh man black mock
turtle necks out the window dude I'm
wearing no shirt I'm wearing no shirt
and [ __ ] it a speedo I'll wear a speedo
dude and people will be like oh you got
that from Bert Kreischer and I didn't do
it
it about this when people say the way I
do it it hits different dude when people
say that it hits there this selfie hits
different dude shut up silver bells
river bells it's Crimson's time in the
city I want to do Carol's caroling I
want to go caroling by myself
imagine that dude imagine going caroling
and there's just one 39 year old and he
just [ __ ] Oh hallelujah hello yeah
hello yeah hello hey Lou yeah and dude
and it's just me in no shirt with a
chain hello guys how you doing man and I
don't even know the words cuz who knows
the words meant oh we comes per rumpa
pum pum he reeks calming Boram pum pum
oh here the guy drummer boy comes BER
rum pum pum pum
mmm he is so holy bum ba-bum pum rum pum
pum rum pum pum pum Liam in the
bean-eating bear dude this is my life
I get why listen this podcast to be
brutally honest I always say I don't
know why you listen but I get why cuz
I'm loosey-goosey dude we're having a
silly goose time and you [ __ ] want to
have that silly goose time but maybe you
can't have that silly goose time because
you got rules and you got work and
you're sitting at a cubicle but I'll
have the [ __ ] silly goose time for
you and you listen to me and secretly
just [ __ ] think about this dude
secretly
maybe you're with your family maybe got
your ear plugs in at the gym maybe right
your cubicle maybe you're a [ __ ]
function and maybe you're listening to
congratulations
maybe listening to me but guess what
dude inside your heart inside that
inside of your heart inside the
compartment of your like when I was a
kid I used to have a [ __ ] dream a
recurring dream and yeah it was [ __ ]
weird dude that I go to sleep and then
did I [ __ ] dream waking up and then
walking into my basement in New Jersey
and walking into the laundry room and
then walking into a secret compartment
into the laundry room and there was a
seance yes did I even know what a seance
was when I was seven no but somehow
dreamt it up there to Christ however in
that part of your heart in the you fall
asleep and dream part of your heart in
the basement part of your heart in the
[ __ ] inside of the secret compartment
in the basement of your heart that you
dreamt up where you're having a seance I
know you're having a silly goose time
doing it and I know maybe you can't live
that way but I'll have it for you listen
to me and we'll escape we'll escape do
it me
you jeremy renner and a few bikini babes
and if you're a girl I'll get some
[ __ ] me you jeremy renner and some
argentinian guys man
they're sexy you ever see him
Argentinian men have the [ __ ] best
chest hair do it cuz it's like a little
bit but not too much but when they work
out it looks good cuz it's a little a
little sweaty but not mad at dude I'd
[ __ ] Argentinean guy I swear to God
if I was gonna [ __ ] a guy who'll be
Archie Argentinian and he'd be six feet
and a little bit hairy speaking of hair
manscaped support for congratulations
comes from manscaped who is the best in
men's grooming below the belt manscaped
offers precision engineered tools for
your family jewels jingle balls to the
walls fellas listen up untrim pubes are
a thing of the past it's time to gear up
and get yourself the gift of shaving
this holiday season I am talking about
the manscape perfect package to point
out I nicked my balls sometimes man when
I did it and I didn't when I did
manscape so guess what you got a
manscaped customer my babies that's what
I do
I [ __ ] Oh with manscape because I
don't want to Nick my balls and they
help me not Nick my balls it's
Revolutionary Company manscaped has
redesigned the electric trimmer their
lawn mower 2.0 has proprietary advanced
skin-safe technology so this trimmer
will nikkor snag your nuts it's also
waterproof so you can use it in the
shower
the lawnmower 2.0 comes inside their
perfect package 2.0 which makes the
perfect gift this holiday season get it
for your dad dude he's probably got
hairy balls and these products smell
good dude
they got they got other crop Reviver the
product the law this product along with
the crop preserver keeper balls from
sweating smelling and sticking and it
smells good
get 20% off you're free and free
shipping with the code Congrats at
manscape com that's 20% off with Free
Shipping at manscape calm and use code
congrats clean up your nuts and make
Santa proud this year Santa shouldn't be
sniffing your nuts but if he is he is
musician butters you're a [ __ ] insel
Sam butters you're an in cell butters
you're more of an themself musician did
you know that as many as seven out of
ten adults wish they played a musical
instrument unfortunately many never do
because they think it's either too late
for them to start too expensive or they
feel like they don't have the time
musician is an online music education
platform rethinking the way people learn
music it's fun easy and affordable and
it's the best way to learn a guitar
bass ukulele or even singing I don't
need to do that but I still use it just
download the app tear I have a good
voice I don't need any help but I still
use it
look you download the app to your
desktop tablet or phone and just start
playing musicians award-winning
technology usually listens to you play
and gives real-time feedback on timing
and accuracy no need for chords or
special equipment with use ition you'll
learn to play your favorite songs faster
than ever and have fun doing it I did it
and they helped me get on key and now
check this out check that out that's
thanks use ition so if you this is all
they need do it hey use ition oh thanks
musician that's their commercial so if
you've been wanting to learn an
instrument or simply want some help
getting back to playing check out use
ition you can get an extended 14-day
free trial Premium Plus package at you
jiton com Congrats
that's unlimited lessons and an
unlimited songs as on as many
instruments as you want for two whole
weeks just go to use ition com /
congrats to start your free trial today
that's why oh you si see I am calm /
congrats congratulations is brought to
you by the cash out the official app of
the log cabin yo what's up that's what's
up man so yeah and you know that's all
good I got I got to tell you something
dude I'm having a [ __ ] we're having a
baby
that's right now I don't share this a
lot I don't share my personal life a lot
in in in in in congratulations because
dude we're just done for a silly goose
time and some people may already know
this maybe maybe some some of you do
know this maybe some of you don't know
this because I've got some creeps out
there that are fans that know the real
deal but dude your boys having a [ __ ]
baby now it makes does it make me
nervous to talk about it yes because you
know that's real life yes and it's not
[ __ ] just me bullshitting and making
fart noises yes but dude I'm having a
baby we are having a baby we are going
to be happy and dude I can't wait till
this [ __ ] comes out of my girl
and it's
to be so dope dude because I'm gonna
dress like the baby and if you think man
a long time ago in a long time ago in
first of all I am so excited if I when I
was in my 20s and I was gonna have a
baby I would be a wreck I would be a
lunatic okay um wasn't financially set
wasn't you know mentally set but right
now I'm firing on all cylinders I'm ever
gonna be okay are you ever ready to have
a kid no but you know that's what's up
with life so I'm here to tell you right
now I'm having a baby dude and it's a
boy
so how [ __ ] cool is that dude and
part of me you know I hadn't brought it
up here on the podcast because I was a
little bit also nervous on how to bring
it up and also I was a little bit
nervous because when I say it I know my
son's gonna grow up and [ __ ] listen
to this [ __ ] and I don't want him
knowing how jerky I am you know I mean
but that's that's it man
and I a long time ago on the podcast I
said I was gonna have a you know my girl
when when I had a family I was gonna
have my girl and my kid and we're all
gonna all dress alike and dude if you
think I'm not doing that with them
you're out of your [ __ ] I'm making
them do it do it first of all it would
be really easy to make the kid do it cuz
he can't do [ __ ] when they kids can't do
[ __ ] when they come out you know they
can't stop you from anything you could
literally have them just eat like you
know kale and they will you know cuz
they have to eat
you'll be terrible to do but I can't
wait to teach my kids stuff like real
hard-hitting issues like what to not do
you know man it's crazy to think about
we got all the clothes and stuff
everyone buys you so many clothes and
every time somebody gives us new clothes
I go like this oh I'm not gonna fit in
that it's a dad joke but I'm a [ __ ]
that's what's up I'm going to
be a dad so dude it's [ __ ] you know dude
holding a kid dude forget it man you
ever hold the kid you ever hold someone
else's kid that [ __ ] feels unbelievable
imagine what it's like holding your kid
you probably know cuz you have kids some
of you I got to learn French though
because I'm gonna [ __ ] I gotta learn
French before the [ __ ] baby comes so
I can just speak to him in French and
then this way he learns Fred that's the
one thing man I wish I had one of those
like Spanish moms or dads this way I
could know Spanish too because they
would just talk to me in Spanish when I
was born but both my parents they talked
to [ __ ] English man and that's a
[ __ ] because now I only know English
but it's a beautiful thing man I'm just
so happy I legit I'm so happy
like I keep thinking about how great
life is cuz life rips dude you know and
I just keep thinking about how life rips
and life just continues to rip more and
more man
and it really is a mind state like
things are going well for me but and I
know you know I know things aren't going
well for everybody and like you're
listening to me right now and I don't
know if I don't know if you're going
through something hard or something or
if your life is great you know who knows
but if you're if you're going through
something and it's tough like I know
it's easier said than done but dude I'm
out here people are out here for you
you know if you don't have family if you
don't have friends or if you feel alone
people are still out here for you I'm
putting another one into the world he'll
be here for you you know and if you know
people are born every [ __ ] minute so
if there's more people maybe they're
here for you they'll be really really an
you can't really uh they won't
understand you because they're new and
they don't they don't they don't speak
in English yet or anything but they will
anyway guys that's what's up and I'm
gonna I'm gonna teach my kid how to
[ __ ] slam that's for sure
I hope his first words are actually no
that's not the truth - just [ __ ] oh
dude imagine your son's first words were
a slam if your son's first words were
just like yeah that's cuz you got fat
belly or if you were just like well
that's because you're sure you [ __ ]
you know yeah well maybe you couldn't
even get into all the rides at
Disneyland cuz you're short well maybe
you should only stop maybe you should
stop eating carbs because you're fake a
tire around your belly that's cuz you're
losing your hair looks like you don't
looks like this line looks like in the
beginning dude
[Music]
Tourette's yeah that's amazing um anyway
dude what else we did the ads what oh
yeah let's do this [ __ ] Eldar dude
this was really cool it touched me we'll
talk about good times and bad times this
is a good segue into this we're bringing
it we're putting an elder here here I
got an email through my producer on the
website it's a log you know I'm gonna
try shorten it up for you guys
but this really this really touched me
dude hey Chris so I have a different
request for you at the title is subject
is my brother hey Chris so I have a
different request for you and the
congratulations podcast to get right to
it I'm coming to you to humbly request
that my brother be given the honor of
becoming an elder now but before I even
go on here let me stop right here so
many people are like am i an elder yet
do I get to be an elder
that's that takes you a few steps back
from becoming an elder okay if you're
asking to become an elder that's like
you want it too bad it's like the
[ __ ] karate guy that's like who do I
have to do to become a black belt you're
in the wrong state of mind young
grasshopper
if you have both your eyes on the prize
then you're not using one of your eyes
for the journey now am i a [ __ ] I'm
practically Confucius how I said that
and that makes me just like him because
I came up with a cool quote that I just
said but dude I actually think I heard
that so I'm not even that smart but this
guy is humbly asking for his brother to
become an elder which he's putting his
self himself aside and trying to have
his brother become an out elder so when
I listen to that when I read that I go
in my head I go I'm listening
right cuz that first hit crystal I have
a different request I go I've heard it
all this is me hey Chris so I have a
different request for you I've heard it
all
that's me to get right to you I'm coming
to you to humbly request yeah sure bro
here comes a joke that's me that my
brother be giving the honor of becoming
an elder and then that's me going I'm
listening I'm like that wee-bey mean ah
[Music]
if I could explain why I believe that
you will understand that my intentions
are pure and true I'm listening he's
talking like he's in a cult I like that
as you have a similar relationship with
your brother that is based on your
complete admiration for each other I
love my brother I love my brother as
much as Gerard but but loves Morgan free
or free and the [ __ ] Angela's fall in
series my brother Justin day is an Air
Force special tactics airman
I'm listening because why because why
because he's protecting me literally
with the 23rd sts do I know what it
means no because I'm I'm really dumb but
maybe some of you out there do he was
deployed to an underdose undisclosed
valley in nor
Eastern Afghanistan in April of 2018
where he was attached to a green beret
unit okay say he's a tough guy anytime I
hear green beret I think okay if I ever
got in a fight with that guy he would
kit would murder me they were tasked to
clear the valley of enemy combatants
from the valley and into Pakistan
approximately a week before he was going
to be sent back home Justin stepped on
an ie D which caused him to lose some
fingers his leg above the knee but also
he had lost so much blood they had
flatlined for 90 seconds which is I mean
what do you even say about that he
survived thank God but recovery was a
horribly difficult process for him
physically but most importantly mentally
PTSD is a disgusting thing to see in
someone you love especially one that I
spent my entire childhood with loving
and admiring I can't [ __ ] imagine man
this is my thank you to you and the
entire congratulations congratulations
podcast then he says some stuff about me
that I'll skip because that just seems
like I'm humble bragging oh this is cool
he introduced you to his spec ops team
and with that you have changed their
vocabulary completely I'm humbled here
thank you
oh he's trying to figure out the design
for a congratulations tattoo please no I
know yeah that's too much nice stuff for
me that's great man
this is so you know it's bittersweet I
read it all very you guys says I love
this he says but mostly I can't think of
a better Christmas gift for him than you
granting him an elder I understand if
not because I know how you have chosen
elders in the past and they were all
deserving thank you for reading all of
this I know it's long as [ __ ] what a
good guy man what a good guy what a good
way to come out someone - there's no
rules but this guy is a sweetheart and
because of this beautiful letter and
because of how selfless you are
I'm going to make your your brother your
hero brother an elder and I'm gonna send
you one too dude
because you didn't ask for it so you
guys are both elders and you can share
that together and thank you for
listening thank you for your service to
justin day and Brayden day thank you for
writing me this message and shoutout to
you and your team out there to your spec
ops team that's just the sweetest man
and sorry you lost your leg a little bit
of your a lot of your leg and your
fingers but just remember that inside
the basement in your laundry room in
your secret compartment in your laundry
room into that [ __ ] candle lit seance
that you know life rips anyway
I [ __ ] I love what you do for this
country and that's amazing and bright
and it sounds like you're a great family
man you you guys both you guys uh yeah
that's that's so cool so we'll be
sending you your your pins and your
certificates wand fire we'll be doing it
and thank you thank you so much all
right that was really sweet
what else do we have
I got a buddy that [ __ ] does so many
[ __ ] herbal drugs and it's insane
dude it's weird like he is like the
first to be like I don't do drugs but
then we'll just be like hey there's this
new thing there's this new plant it's
only in Corpus Christi and if you
literally all you have to do is just eat
it
burn it a little bit and eat it you want
to do it and I'm like man I've never
done drugs he's like it's not drugs it's
not drugs I'm like eh well I don't do
that and then he's like okay and then
he'll start eating it and taking some
like the herbal pills and then [ __ ]
one hour later he's like because that's
the thing dude if you say if you say
anything that's the part that's part of
what it is and then
I don't that's right I have gray hair I
don't have gray hair I'm a a my my beard
because it doesn't [ __ ] kissing
youthful I'm illiterate aging backwards
and I'm like alright well okay so I'm
not taking that cuz I don't want to be
[ __ ] talking about I don't be the guy
at coffee bean it's amazing how how many
times I go to this coffee bean and just
there's always one crazy person that it
it's like they have them there for me to
[ __ ] just be like and it's sometimes
it's so hard to usually you can tell by
the way their dress that they're crazy
but one person I thought with two crazy
people yesterday one was that Ralph's
and they go like this hey man we call
the cops for me and I go like this no I
don't think so man and I went into
grouse and he said okay need the cops
and I said alright cool man we'll just
you figure that out there that's it okay
now I knew he was crazy because he had
dirt all over his face okay
also nothing was going on that was bad
and he was asking me to call the cops
now all good uh also another person came
into the coffee bean and she had a
hoodie on and it was pulled up over her
head fine and she says hey can I talk to
you outside for a second and I said no
no no I don't think so I'm just gonna
stay here and I got some work to do on
my phone and then she looked at my phone
and I was just on Twitter then I thought
about covering up then I realized who
gives a [ __ ] she's crazy and she said
okay because you know Dave Navarro
I literally said huh she said can I talk
to you outside for a second and I said
no I don't think so I'm working on some
stuff and she said okay do you know Dave
Navarro and I said yeah yeah
and she said well he took my workshop
and I said uh okay just yeah so I just
I'm looking for a place to stay okay
well I have to do with that why did you
bring Dave Navarro into this
she said yeah cuz it just sucks man I'm
looking for like a donation do I need a
place to stay I'm looking for donations
and it's just like rough failure you
know I've been in LA too long a long
time and you know other people like
Madonna and all those people they've all
they've all covered my songs and they
all you know they all devolved they all
cover my songs and I've ever written for
them and it's great but I just think you
know I need to I need to get a place to
stay imagine if I was just like I'll do
want you to stay at my house come on
just stay at my house stay at my house
hangout
well I think it's probably I would get
stabbed
but whatever what's up with this Top Gun
[ __ ] it stop you know they keep trying
to make more they keep trying to make
remake these shit's like John wick too
and and matrix for bizarre John wick for
and matrix for is they're coming out on
the same day and that's such a good
[ __ ] idea and that's so dope because
and Keanu Reeves is the best person to
do that because you're having both the
franchises come out with the number four
or is it the sake it is it the same not
network production I don't know it's
gonna be so good for both of them that's
how people think it's not good for
movies to come out on the same day I
guess it's not if they're completely
remember that [ __ ] remember that year
that that movie volcano came out and
Dante's Inferno
Ferno I think they came out the same day
Dante's let me just let me let's ask
Siri dude when did Dante's Inferno come
out of course they're gonna do the book
yes don't taste peak that's what it was
when did Dante's Peak come out Dan tees
peak was released February 7th 1997 dude
antes peak in the beanie in giing
1997 they said right okay when did the
movie volcano come out which one you
[ __ ] idiot the 1 1997 right here was
released April 25th 1997 bro let me tell
you something right out they've released
two volcano movies in the same year now
that's a [ __ ] bad idea now let me
tell you why because here's what
happened one studio for sure and now so
we're making a volcano movie and then
the other studio was like we got to make
our volcano movie and they tried to beat
the other one of the punch now that
makes both of them tanked one of them
was starring
pierce brosnan and one of them was
starring Tommy Lee Jones I believe now
all I have to say about that is sit 90s
dude if you ever asked anyone what the
most 90s thing is it's that there were
two volcano movies that came out the
same year and one was with Pierce
Brosnan and one was with Tommy Lee 90s
Jones that's more 90s then googling 2003
and Ludacris shows up by the way if you
google 2003 for real one of the first I
made a joke about this I'm a podcast I
googled 2003 images bro Ludacris comes
up I'm not [ __ ] with you I did it the
other day and Ludacris his face was one
of the first Google images that comes up
look at this are you think I'm lyin bro
and I looked at that and I took one step
back and I went Cadillac frills I said
woah hold on a second did you know how
that Cadillac spells ludecke dude I made
the joke in the podcast and then I tried
it and then Ludacris's face came up
fourth i'm prophet get Electra is
collect Brill's board just check out how
am I gonna let brillz bro Ludacris
I can't the amount the amount I think
about Ludacris is unreal and if and
honestly I want you to [ __ ] I want to
make a real [ __ ] I want to make an
honest statement here if you're in your
30s or 40s and you don't think about
Ludacris every few days I don't want to
[ __ ] anything to do with you
that's absolute [ __ ] can you hear
that in the thing do you think alright
I'm getting [ __ ] work done on my
house and these guys are just drilling
and drilling dude um it's fine dude
because I'm respectful and I do how I do
and I have my [ __ ] podcast how I have
my podcast and it goes when it goes and
if you hear drilling in the background
then we're all getting our house worked
on okay
anyway Dante's Inferno and [ __ ] or
Dante's Peak and volcano came out the
same year dude how [ __ ] you is that also
don't make a volcano movie period don't
even make one and if you're gonna and
you have man I was 17 when that [ __ ]
came out and I would be like dude hey
guys this is gonna bomb I always know
when the movies gonna bomb
it's so obvious when the movies gonna
bomb it is completely obvious when the
movies gonna bomb and everyone knows it
and everyone in Hollywood pretends like
it's still not gonna bomb and it's gonna
Bob let's look at bombs of - of 2019
box-office blunders bombs let's this is
like a box off his blunders a biggest
box-office bomb look at this I don't
know some of these look hell boy 2019
with that guy
what the [ __ ] his name great actor
knew it was gonna bomb you don't reboot
something [ __ ] five years later bomb
City hell boy bomb City
Oh Gemini man dude I love Will Smith
he's great
how did you not know how did you not
know um what else is there
oh my god what is this Oh [ __ ] steel
with Shaq that was in 1997 yeah but okay
cool Waterworld was the ultimate that's
the thing there are these stars like
Kevin Costner that just get to the point
where they're 50 something and it's like
and you and you watch them and
you and they were killing it but you
gonna put on another movie and everyone
everyone is like kay-kay and they're
like but we're starting a new thing
Waterworld
or Gemini man and everyone sits back and
we're like okay we're like very softly
we like yeah but Kay right and then all
the [ __ ] comes out it's got all the
bells and whistles but okay did you see
the first preview like okay and then you
watch the movie you're like okay you
know let's look up more box-office bombs
box-office bombs 2019 I knew all of
these by the way uh okay here we go
sixteen box office flops this year and
their release days dates drunk and the
release days come on dude
I clicked on it damn it uh according to
the battery no some of these all right
here we go oh man I don't even know
these Playmobil the movie okay here's
the thing uh Oh Dark Phoenix I actually
didn't know about I didn't I couldn't
tell that one because it's an x-men
thing I thought was gonna kill it
replicas with counter reeves that that
depth bomb I don't even know what that
was some of these I don't know what it
was the kid who would be king don't know
what it is
serenity knew though miss Bala don't
even know what it is captive state don't
even know what it is
who was in this who is this what is that
captive state the beach bum with Matthew
McConaughey whatever
Hellboy knew it don't reboot a movie
[ __ ] five years after the [ __ ]
last one came out and it's what is these
movies are so I don't even know what
they are
Oh Toki and yeah I knew that was gonna
bomb with that [ __ ] gorgeous girl in
it Phil Collins daughter and the other
guy Dark Phoenix the check out des Dark
Phoenix opening weekend 32 million
budget 200 million total globalgirl
grossed 252 million now
so why is that a bomb what's this one
the kitchen oh I love Tiffany Haddish
love all those actors knew that was
gonna bomb the Goldfinch then hadn't I
never know a movie with that much brown
in it with like tan and all that
everything every room they go in was
like gold and tan and brown any movie
like that I have no idea if it's gonna
bomb or not because I just don't give a
[ __ ] about it make more colors in your
movie dude um Gemini man yeah it's funny
that some of these are bomb how are
these bombs are still out doctor sleep
Playmobil the movie oh my god production
budget 40 million opening weekend
700,000 K look at this quote critics
best watched running in the background
of a playdate for preschoolers buried
under the noise of kids on imaginations
by offering the occasional distraction
from a total toddler meltdown uh say
specifically rude
[Music]
Tourette's um anyway my friends are
[ __ ] mmm Al Pacino and Sylvester
Stallone [ __ ] you they're all my friends
dude they're not my friends I know them
and I love them and I respect them but
they don't they barely know me um I did
go to [ __ ] Sylvester Stallone's house
the other day which was the absolute
most insane thing that has ever happened
he [ __ ] wrote me on Instagram and he
was like you want to come over and he
was like you want to come hang we're
having watching the fight and I was like
sure and I went and then I mean I don't
even know how to tell this story dude
but I was there and he was like hey come
on in you know some of these guys and
Bill burr was there I was I got ten cod
bills there I feel like I knew and four
other dudes that all looked like
Sylvester Stallone one was his brother
legitimately and one was Michael Strahan
and I was like what's going on here and
then I'm hanging and then all of a
sudden
behind me I hear oh hey and I look and
[ __ ] Al Pacino's there ah
and I'm like what the [ __ ] going on oh
don't mind me
oh don't mind me said something like
that and I was like oh hey I'm Chris and
he goes I guess hey Wow how's that kay
and I walk over to the side a little bit
and I'm like whoa am i doing is
everything okay this is a dream and then
frank grillo shows up know him joe
carnahan no i don't know if i met him
before or not but we [ __ ] it felt
like i already knew him great director
love the gray he did the gray love that
movie love that movie and then Kalin
shows up they brought a bottle of wine
like a piece of [ __ ] you know like dude
you know nice gesture but alright that's
the same thing that's what Kalin is and
then he said to Ali was like how Pacino
he was like hey man you were great in
the Irishman and I was just like this
guy hey really really great in the
Irishman hey what are you doing hey dude
that's Al Pacino of course he was great
in the Irishman you [ __ ] dunce
there's like oh I don't know I don't
know oh and then and then Kalin was like
well I have some notes and he was like
oh ha ha ah and then [ __ ] I swear I'm
hanging out and I look Stallone's like
look or some reason he says hey or
something I looked behind me and [ __ ]
arms Schwarzenegger walks in and I'm
like oh I did and then Stallone goes
like this it gets better
and I was like better who's showing up
Frank Sinatra and then we go to the
kitchen Guy Fieri's cooking this is like
a [ __ ] weird dream you have and then
and then
and then uh I forget which one it was
but one of Stallone's daughters like I
can't believe Guy Fieri's here I dressed
up as him for Halloween one year and I
was like I went as your dad and then
[ __ ] David Blaine shows up and does
magic real magic by the way saw it with
my own eyes and then [ __ ] Sugar Ray
Leonard shows up it was so insane dude
it was so great so thanks sly for
inviting me I really appreciate you
always been a huge fan now it's cool to
know you as the person and see what a
great family and what a great guy yaar
it was awesome though I don't wanna say
too much on the podcast you know
suffering but I really appreciated it
and that's it what up do we do it yeah
we pretty much did it should we do
anything else remember the Harlem shake
remember that [ __ ] that [ __ ] paint
paint paint be any any slight I'm white
dude I'm gonna work on that I am
actually way too [ __ ] pasty for real
I like I saw a picture myself the other
day and I thought I gotta get a tan I I
don't use um I don't I don't use what do
you call it filters on snapchat or
[ __ ] whatever it is Instagram that
much but I I the other day I think I
actually did because I looked so white
so that means times are a-changing but
I'm not even 40 yet dude you know so
life is [ __ ] really looking up I can
get a tan easily by a [ __ ] two in
place I never went to a tan place I
should go to a team place tanning salon
salon the nerve that they call it as a
Salon salon always makes me think of my
[ __ ] grandma
one time my grandma was [ __ ] like 70
something years old and she got her hair
cut and she and and she said do you like
my haircut and I said yeah and she said
if I feel like it makes me look younger
ha ha ha that's cute as [ __ ] man
if you're 78 you kind of can't say that
you know you're just 78 I got my hair
cut a little bit shorter though I look
younger man but I'm the youngest man
alive you sons of [ __ ]
I guess that's an hour
I got nothing really yeah well you know
what we can do is first of all you can
text me let me get this in this here you
text me on the community on community
and my number is eight one eight two
three nine seventy eighty seven and then
also you can come see me in Chicago I
want to be at Chicago New Year's Eve and
that's what's up
can't wait to do that you can get
tickets to get to get to Crystal Concha
cago Illinois I've got three shows two
of them are sold out the last one comes
celebrate
bring in ring in in the meaning Ewing
get the ring in the beginning of the new
year
bring in bring in the beginning being of
the new year 10:00 p.m.
Chicago Illinois December 31st get
tickets now Chris Chris Lea calm and
then I'm gonna be in [ __ ] Orillia
Ontario January 18th and 17th and 18th I
would say 18th and 17th if you're
[ __ ] how about when people do that
that's weird as [ __ ] when they did the
late last number first working on some
new [ __ ] in her vine California I'm
doing a club because I'm gonna work on
some new [ __ ] I got a start writing a
little bit more Pasadena Ice House West
Palm Beach Florida
Robinson Mississippi for some reason and
then I got my Las Vegas sheds I think
I'm gonna do the fighter and the kid
this week because they keep asking me to
do it but let's listen to this one more
time because this [ __ ] made me a
laugh bro and then oh I'm on riffin with
Griffin [ __ ] this week I already did
it there's a good calm good conversation
about we had it about stand-up comedy
and [ __ ] like that with Eric
and my body in being ninguém and so I
did that
hey when you can sec-1 this white boy
waiters one that's fake in the beginning
this is lady in the beanie in the
beginning they're saying this is fake
yeah in D and then there's a real one
okay this is the fake one in the same
fake evening
yeah in in the binning ding in EDP
what's the real one
be original oh this is the real one okay
we announce that our membership figures
stood at 769 810 700 listen properly
seven hundred and sixty nine thousand
eight hundred and twenty so funny okay
there are absolutely funny ants event
members down from 110 100 point two
million in 2012 everyone checked out
just everyone goes I guess if they cut
to the [ __ ] audience when you 700
1997 7 1.2 everyone goes like this we
don't have to listen anymore we don't
have to listen anymore he's just saying
numbers we just hang out wow I like in a
beginning game better though Wow [ __ ]
dude
the originals funny as [ __ ] to listen
properly
like it's their fault that's the best
Wow okay well that's it my babies
we're all great we're having a good time
my back hurts and I got tennis elbow but
it's all good
download the cash up for free on the App
Store Google Play market get ticket to
see me Cresselia com Chicago that's the
next one Peoria and Chicago and Chicago
and subscribe to the youtube channel
that helps that it really helps if you
rate the show on iTunes and stuff like
that so please do that my new special is
coming up in a few months I mean you the
show you second season coming up on
December 26th I believe it that's
Christmas at midnight yeah Christmas at
midnight and then that's it and then
army of the Dead is coming up later all
right guys you're the best thank you so
much and that's it thank you
[Music]